في اللحظة التي ترى فيها الأم
ابنتها للمرة الأولى بعد 8
سنوات في
السجون الإسرائيلية، يخفف الألم والفرح المطلق،
كان ميك سلمان جزءًا من
الموجة الأولى من تبادل الأسرى
بين إسرائيل وحماس،
ثم تم اتهام 16 عامًا
بمحاولة  طعن إسرائيليين
تقول السلطات الإسرائيلية إنه لم يصب أحد بأذى،
ومع ذلك فقد أُدينت بمحاولة
القتل وحُكم عليها بالسجن لمدة 10 سنوات عندما
استأنفت عائلتها الحكم، وقد قضت
مليك ما يقرب من ثمانية سنوات من تلك السنوات
وقضت ما تبقى من
سنوات مراهقتها خلف القضبان مع عائلتها.  تؤكد
براءتها والدة فاطمة ملك التي
حلمت بهذا اليوم منذ سنوات باحتضان
ابنتها لمشاركة تلك الفرحة مع
مجتمعها، وتقول إن
رفض إطلاق سراحك لا يعني
أنك حر تمامًا. وزير الأمن القومي الإسرائيلي
تيمار بيناف الذي تم العثور عليه هو نفسه
مذنب في عام 2007 ولكن قبل أن يصبح
وزيرا للتحريض على العنصرية ضد
العرب ودعم منظمة إرهابية، أصدر بيناف
تعليماته
للقوات الإسرائيلية باستخدام قبضة حديدية لمنع
الفلسطينيين من الاحتفال
بالإفراج عن أحبائهم قائلا إن
السجناء
إرهابيون تعبيرا عن الفرح أو الدعم
لـ  احتفالات النصر الإرهابية
تعطي القوة لنفس هؤلاء الحثالة البشرية
هؤلاء النازيين، السياسة هنا
واضحة جدًا جدًا بعدم السماح بهذه
التعبيرات عن الفرح والسعي بحزم
لإجراء اتصالات ووقف أي دعم لهؤلاء
النازيين في ليلة أخرى، مشهد آخر
للقوات الإسرائيلية وهي تزيل المهنئين
والصحفيون في منزل أحد
السجون الفلسطينية المفرج عنها يتخذون
نهجًا متشددًا بناءً على أمر
وزير الأمن القومي في بيت لحم
بالضفة الغربية المحتلة، تمكنوا من تحدي بيناف
احتفالًا بالإفراج عن فاطمة شاهين
وآخرين من
المدينة التي تركتها FMA  عادت إلى المنزل سيرًا على الأقدام
وعادت بعد 7 أشهر تقريبًا مع
إصابات غيرت حياتها برصاص
جنود إسرائيليين واتهمت بمحاولة
القتل
لعدة أشهر. تقول عائلة fma إنهم
مُنعوا من الوصول حتى مع استمرار احتجازها
في إسرائيل، وتقول FMA إنها حاولت القتل، ومع
ذلك تم احتجازها فقط دون توجيه تهم
إليها.  لم تذهب إلى المحاكمة، ولم تُمنح
أي فرصة للدفاع عن نفسها،
وهذه قصة نسمعها مرارًا
وتكرارًا من سجن التحرير،
حيث لم يتم منحهم الإجراءات القانونية الواجبة،
ومع ذلك فإن هذه الجريمة موجودة إلى جانب
أسمائهم في خدمة السجون الرائيلي
ردت سي إن إن على هذه الادعاءات قائلة إن
سجناء الأمن الوطني الذين تم
إطلاق سراحهم من السجون الإسرائيلية خلال
اليومين الماضيين كانوا يقضون أحكامًا على
جرائم خطيرة مثل محاولة القتل
والاعتداء وإلقاء المتفجرات. جميع
السجناء في عهدة مصلحة السجون الإسرائيلية محتجزون
وفقًا
للقانون وهذا غير صحيح.  أسفل
الأرقام الواردة في قائمة تضم 300
سجين فلسطيني حددتهم إسرائيل على أنهم
مؤهلون للإفراج عنهم، تم إدراج 80% منهم على أنهم
محتجزون للتو، مما يعني أنه لم
يتم
الحكم عليهم رسميًا، تطبق إسرائيل نظامين
قانونيين في الأراضي المحتلة،
الفلسطينيون تحت الجيش، والإسرائيليون
تحت الحكم المدني.  القانون الذي يضع حدًا منخفضًا
لاعتقال أعداد متزايدة من
الفلسطينيين،
وبينما يسعى المتشددون الإسرائيليون مثل بيناف
وآخرين في هذه الحكومة اليمينية المتطرفة
إلى وصف كل فلسطيني بأنه
إرهابي، فإن هذا العدد يتزايد كل
يوم.